voilà cette enquête et cette enquête
minutieuse pour retrouver l'identité de
ces migrants morts en méditerranée
pourquoi pourquoi ce travail est il si
important derrière les statistiques on
l'a vu il y a des vies perdues qui sont
ces femmes et ces hommes prêts à tout
risquer pour venir ici en europe et
pourquoi est-il si difficile de
concilier nos politiques migratoires
avec ce qu'ils peuvent
ce qui peut apparaître comme des
principes élémentaires d'humanité c'est
avec toutes ces questions que nous
laisse ce film très fort très émouvant
numéro 3 187 disparu en méditerranée
signé madeleine leroyer et pour
approfondir à présent j'accueille ici
sur ce plateau didier leschi bonjour un
jour vous êtes directeur de l'office
français de l'immigration et de
l'intégration à vos côtés ibrahim
tounkara bonjour bonjour vous êtes
vous-même réfugiés originaires de côte
d'ivoire et cette même année 2015
l'année de ce drame dont nous venons de
parler vous avez effectué cette
traversée vous y avez perdu un de vos
amis avec lequel vous aviez embarqué
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
aujourd'hui ici sur ce plateau masqués
comme il se doit en raison des
conditions sanitaires alors à distance
avec nous en direct de milan nous sommes
avec christina cattaneo bon jour on vous
a vu dans le film vous êtes médecin
légiste et vous faites partie de cette
équipe qui a oeuvré pour
l'identification des disparus et nous
sommes également avec sandro gozi
bonjour bonjour vous êtes aujourd'hui
député européen vous avez été élu sur la
liste
lrm française et vous étiez en charge
des affaires européennes au sein du
gouvernement italien de 2014 à 2018
autrement dit au moment où
le président du conseil matteo renzi a
pris la décision de renflouer l'épave de
ce bateau alors qu'il tenait d'abord
commencer par vous donner la parole
ibrahim tounkara parce que je le disais
cette expérience dont il est question
dans le film vous l'avez vécu vous êtes
vous avez traversé la méditerranée au
péril de votre vie et vous avez regardé
ce film qui évidemment j'imagine a
ravivé beaucoup de souvenirs mais
évidemment sauf une barre avait beaucoup
de souvenirs parce que je sais je me
suis rendu compte après avoir regardé ce
film
combien de fois j'ai eu de la chance
parce que je suis passé moi même à deux
doigts de connaître le même sort que ses
850 personnes ont connu parce que au
départ des rallyes vu notre bateau était
troué et malgré ce risque là libyens ils
nous ont autorisés à prendre la mer et
quand nous avons atteint les eaux
internationales
l'eau est entrée dans notre bateau
jusqu'à atteindre cheville et comme si
cela ne suffisait pas des jerrycans qui
contenait de licences se renverser dans
le dos mais qui étaient dans le bateau
et sa forme et un cocktail explosif qui
nous brûlait enlever complètement la
peau et ça crée un bois un sauve qui
peut et dans se sauve qui peut il ya une
dizaine d une colonne de dizaines de
dauphins qui sont sortis et qui nous ont
guidés jusqu'au bout jusqu'au grand
bateau donc évidemment ça me rappelle
beaucoup de souvenirs et vous avez donc
été secourus en l'air par un parent un
navire d'une organisation solaire didier
leschi vous êtes haut fonctionnaire est
évidemment vous êtes fait partie de ces
personnes qui par leur fonction doivent
regarder ces questions migratoires avec
une distance nécessaire j'imagine
pourtant qu'on ne sort pas complètement
indemne du film que nous venons de voir
non bien sûr on n'en sort pas indemne et
en même temps je crois qu'on doit se
dire que c'est un film qui est à
l'honneur de
de l'italie quinon s'est en particulier
la société italienne
l'effort qui a été fait en matière
d'accueil
il ya là une volonté politique
c'est à l'image de ce que nous doit ce
qu'on doit être au niveau européen c'est
à dire des gens soucieux de la vie des
autres en tout cas de leur dignité au de
là de des drames qui peuvent qu ils
peuvent connaître et c'est ce que montre
ce film quand on oublie parfois que
derrière les chiffres les statistiques
dont on parle le nombre de morts il y à
il ya des femmes et des hommes
oui bien sûr on ne l'oublient pas c'est
bien sûr qu'on le sait voilà et en même
temps on sait que l'europe est une des
principales zones d'immigration au monde
avec l'amérique du nord et que d'une
certaine manière ce film montre ce que
peu de sociétés à travers le monde sont
capables de faire c'est à dire investir
de l'humanité en même temps de l'argent
pour essayer de montrer ce que chacun a
droit c'est-à-dire au-delà de la mort
une reconnaissance
alors cette reconnaissance christina
catena au vous y travaillez vous y
travaillez encore puisque le travail
dont il est question dans le film et
dont vous êtes l'une des chevilles
ouvrières comme médecin légiste ce
travail continue à la fin du film on
nous dit que deux personnes ont été
identifiées
il y en a un petit peu plus un depuis
oui c'est dans ces derniers deux ans on
a identifié six personnes mais c'est un
cri lancé mais c'est très très lente
parce qu'il n'y a pas de fond parce que
je souviens que les activités
scientifiques sont à seulement faite par
l'une et les universités il ya douze
universités italiens qui sont en train
de travailler sur l'adn sur beaucoup de
choses mais s'il n'y a pas de fonds bon
on peut pas aller plus vite et je pense
que cette expérience doit montrer à
l'europe parce que c'est un accident
les victimes sont en europe
les parents beaucoup de parents sont en
europe c'est une question européenne
donc ça a été un grand expérimentant
entre guillemets et il faut
alors que maintenant c'est à elle de
continuer parce que comme si c'était un
avion d'italiens plein d'italiens ou de
france est bon le but c'est ça l'europe
elle était en quelque sorte présente
avec nous puisque nous avons nous sommes
avec eux sandro bondi qui vous êtes
député européen et s'est rappelée dans
le film la décision de renflouer ce
bateau elle est prise par le
gouvernement italien dont vous êtes dont
vous étiez membres échoue il faut nous
rappeler quand même les raisons qui
poussent matteo renzi et son
gouvernement a décidé de renflouer cette
épave
tout d'abord les principes des bases
c'est lui qui ressort du film qu'on a vu
et que l'humanité vient 20 la politique
et vient va aussi l'argent public est
nécessaire pouvoir faire des opérations
de séjour moi je m'en souviens très bien
de ce week-end c'était l'édifice i-tele
week end plus difficile de mon
expérience du gouvernement on était à la
fois choqué et enragé choqué parce que
c'était une tragédie avec des
proportions sans précédent par rapport à
ce qui c'était c'est arrivé à vent
enragé parce que on l'avait dit à
plusieurs reprises à nos partenaires
européens qui les europe était en train
de mourir de la méditerranée qui
l'émaillent dernier était devenue un
cimetière à cause de l'égoïsme de
l'indifférence nos partenaires européens
et malheureusement s'est vite lassée
cimetière à vieux augmenter énormément
sa population et donc on était très
engagé et c'est pour cela que on a été
convoqué d'urgence
au palais qui gît qui est un peu les
matignon italien et on a décidé de
demander pour la nième fois mais cette
fois ci on n'avait rien eu on a réussi à
convoquer les premières sommet
extraordinaire des leaders européens
premier conseil européen extraordinaire
dédié à l'immigration c'était la
première fois et depuis on a essayé d en
a cédé travailler mais les principes
sains principes d'humanité et nos
partenaires européens
on avait du mal à le comprendre et me
semble qu'ils aient encore encore encore
impayés du mal quand honneur à la main
dans la mer il faut sauver les gens
avancent des six mondes et qui doit
assumer la responsabilité pour qui avant
de discuter la répartition des migrants
la répartition des demandeurs d'asile
il faut intervenir et il faut sauver
sauver les migrants et c'est comme
justement même de ce point de vue comme
celle de celui de la délibération comme
un professeur catania disent eh bien
c'est une responsabilité européenne a
rejeté que nous écoutions à nouveau
jeudi l'un des protagonistes du film
c'est cette chercheuse que l'on voit
feuilleter des registres d'état civil
sur lesquels figure une trace une simple
trace de ces migrants dont on a retrouvé
le corps mais dont on ne connaît pas le
nom l'autre c'est la dernière tentative
désespérée de redonner une dignité à ces
morts c'est une forme de respect pour le
défunt
même si on ne se connaît pas
même s'il ne fait pas partie de ma
famille de mes proches c'est quand même
une personne qui est morte et qui est
venu à disparaître et 10 passes je fais
ça pour la justice tête justice pour le
respect et l espoir qu elle aussi
d'après la justice et injustice aux
morts quel hertha a du style
en réalité faire justice aux morts
j'insiste d'honorer les morts
ça servira dé tels que non parce que
nous notre civilisation notre condition
d'être civilisé comme est entièrement se
mesure à la façon dont nous traitons les
morts il décède en route et christina
catena au cattaneo il il ya derrière ce
témoignage
une question pourquoi et surtout pour
qui faites vous tout ce que vous faites
depuis six ans maintenant
évidemment pour les familles j'imagine
mais aussi pour pour nous on nous dit
que c'est l'honneur des européens
oui bon c'est l'honneur de développer
quelque chose qui ne convient pas à
transmettre bien comme médecin légiste
c'est l'importance de l'identité donc
c'est oui c'est très important de se
souvenir de la dignité des morts de
l'honneur de mort l'importance de de lui
donner un nom et
une sépulture mai mais la chose la plus
importante du poids je pense que c'est
de se rappeler que derrière ces gens ces
deux villes du vivant derrière le mans
il ya des vivants et en première chose
on identifie les m'entourent les vivants
parce qu'il ya des raisons
administratives
il ya les orphelins qui ont besoin du
certificat de man et sans l'identité on
ne peut pas donner les certificats
demande et on sait comment on a besoin
de certificat de man qu'il ya des gens
pour pour continuer à vivre mais surtout
on connais très bien la maladie
non la pathologie delà de la perte
ambiguë les anglais la peine des
violences on sait déjà dans le pot de
vie scientifique la mère le père et d'un
fils à qui on ne sait pas s'il est
vivant ou mort porte à d'une pathologie
psychiatrique sickology qu'on ne sait
déjà c'est c'est déjà publiés et donc
c'est fondamental d'identifier les morts
pour la santé mentale des vivants et ça
devient un droit à la santé
christina cattaneo six personnes
identifiées en six ans sur plusieurs
centaines est-ce que vous ne cédez pas
parfois au découragement
est ce que vous ne dites pas parfois à
quoi bon tout cela ah oui absolument
mais d'un point de vue pratique si
personne dans ce dans ce 4 cette
catastrophe c'est rien c'est beaucoup
pour récit familles qui ont reçu une
réponse ou qui vont recevoir une réponse
dans le scénario de tous les marchés
c'est un peu mais et je dois rappeler
que cette activité cette grande activité
de l'italien je dois dire que je dois
souligner que cette fois je suis très
fier d'être italienne est quelque chose
qui est entre guillemets je le répète on
expérimente c'est quelque chose qui a
été fait pour deux montrer ce que les
gens disaient on peut pas les identifier
mais ces gens ne cherchent pas seulement
les ont pas besoin de les identifier
et ça a été une bataille pour deux
montré pour les identifier
oui c'est ça mais pour démontrer que il
peut être fait on peut les identifier
sur le
la catastrophe de lampedusa on en a
identifié 50 pas seulement 6 mai et
qu'il faut les identifier
c'est ça le vrai message ibrahim
tounkara vous vous écoutez ce débat
depuis tout à l'heure c'est très
important pour les pour les familles des
victimes pour les familles des disparus
d'avoir une possibilité que leurs
proches soient identifiés oui c'est très
important pour les familles d'avoir de
la nouvelle qui ont été arrachés d'une
demande est atroce à l'affection des
siens 27 mai blues de cadavres que je ne
citerai pas la méditerranée et pour moi
c'est très important
mais au-delà de ça moi la question que
je me pose qu'est ce que font les
gouvernements pour aider ces
associations madame balader tout à
l'heure et avec le peu de moins que
l'association des associations on est
elles font ce qu'elles peuvent d'où le
nom peu élevé de corps identifiés et
donc on doit se poser la question sur la
politique des toiles des états européens
qui est réservé aux personnes de la
vivent et pour ne pas que ce genre de
catastrophes en arrive et je me souviens
l'europe a conclu un accord avec les
mills un libyen les doutes de beaucoup
de millions d'euros pour intercepter les
migrants souvent dans des eaux elle
quand les honneurs dans les eaux
internationales et en dépit des accords
internationaux et les ramener en italie
et pas de les ramener en libre en libye
de ramener en libye et dans des
conditions que personne ne peut imaginer
on va évoquer dans quelques minutes les
la manière s'il y en a une de limiter
ces drames
quelques mots tout de même puisque
évidemment nous parlons de
l'identification de ces migrants mais il
ya des chiffres il faut les rappeler
tout de même
sur les morts en méditerranée vingtaine
21 mille réfugiés ont trouvé la mort
c'est une estimation
depuis 2014 en méditerranée on se
demande quand même
didier leschi si parfois par ce type
d'opération on ne se donne pas bonne
conscience à bon compte quand on est
européen par rapport voilà à ce qui nous
évite de parler des problèmes qu'on
évoquait à l'instant c'est à dire la
nécessité de stopper de stopper les flux
au départ je crois pas que ce soit une
question de de bon compte
on essaye de prendre en charge la
complexité je dirais du monde voilà on
d'un côté il y à cet effort et en
particulier les efforts que font les
états vis en finançant en subventionnant
des organisations non gouvernementales
ou en utilisant les universités leurs
fonctionnaires pour faire des opérations
qui participe justement comme le disait
tout à l'heure la personne dans
l'extrait qu'on a qu'on a vue de la
conception qu'on a de notre commune
humanité c'est vrai que la manière de
traiter les morts eh bien c'est ce qui
me distingue de rentrer dans l'espèce
humaine
mais on ne peut pas se passer de ce que
fait madame cattaneo etc
on peut pas se passer de bénévoles en
l'occurrence ce sont des bénévoles
pardon ce sont des bénévoles qu'on voit
dans ce film au delà de l'opération je
ne crois pas que ce soit de bénévoles
je veux dire ils ont un salaire quand on
est enseignante à l'université ont aussi
payé par l'université enfin je ne crois
pas qu'ils soient bénévoles voilà c'est
ça vous paraît voilà et j'ai bien
compris que c'était
c'était des organismes internationaux
qui qui participe est sa voix la lia la
croix rouge internationale et donc ses
sims est subventionné par les états est
ce qu'à fait le remorquage ou la sortie
de l'épave par le gouvernement italien
s'est pas fait par dvd vol des faits par
des salariés et s'est payé par le
gouvernement italien demande peut-être
là-dessus d'ailleurs peut-être on pas
parler ou non
deux mauritaniens mois sans drogba
cattaneo peut-être là-dessus la manière
dont se décident les choses on en a
parlé mais peut-être la manière dont
elles se financent sandro gozi quand
vous choisissez quand vous décidez avec
le gouvernement italien de faire vous
savez que ça va coûter de l'argent non
seulement pour renflouer l'épave mais
ensuite aussi pour identifier les
migrants d'abord je crois qu'elle a
presque atteint explique l'asm a
expliqué qu'elle a été par ce une base
parfaitement volontaire c'est qu'elle a
fait et c'est remarquable je veux encore
une fois la remercier
quand nous avons fait à l'époque quand
j'étais bien j'étais au gouvernement
normal à la question êtes vous l'avez
vous l'avez dit de très bien
derrière les chiffres derrière les
numéros il y à des femmes des enfants
des enfants et des hommes et il ya un
principe que vous avez ton à en france
dans la devise de la république
française c'est le principe de
fraternité passé de fraternité saint
principe universel ne vaut pas seulement
dans l'hexagone et ne vaut pas seulement
pour les italiens les français vaut pour
toute l'humanité et les principes de
base de l'humanité c'est d assurer la
paix après la mort surtout quand on aux
moeurs dans ces conditions donc d'aider
pouvoir identifier les morts c'était
c'est un principe fondamental d'humanité
ça a coûté de l'argent public
oui nous avons été attaqués par la
droite italienne et elle est sereine
droite italienne pour ça oui oui je m'en
souviens des sénateurs gaspari a
d'autres qui nous ont attaqué en disant
que nous faisions de la propagande
humanitaire moi je rêve on dit que c'est
que nous avons fait parce que je crois
que c'est ça fait partie de notre
conception des gérer une question il
n'ya pas de distinction entre la densité
politique dé gérer la l'immigration la
nécessité de trouver des politiques de
développer des politiques plus efficaces
au niveau européen et les principes
d'humanité
mais quand il s'agit de vieux de morte
moi je crois que les principes
d'humanité doit venir avant la question
de l'argent public où la question des
qui fait quoi alors pour clore cette
question est très rapidement s'il vous
plaît christine marin cattaneo
dites nous un petit peu comment les
choses se sont organisés entre la
puissance publique et puis les
organisations les ong éventuellement les
universités mais c'est pas facile parce
qu'il sait pas ma langue donc mais en
tout cas je vais chercher de m'expliquer
bon les ong il ya seulement seulement
d'un point de vue technique le csr qui
est en train de travailler et ancien
centre de le comité international de la
croix rouge
exactement ce sont de e2 de parler avec
les et les vivants et les parents de
chercher des parents mais du côté des
morts il ya ce pour ce bateau pour cette
catastrophe il y a seulement un petit
bureau qui n'a pas d'argent dans le
gouvernement iranien et il ya douze
universités
bon moi je suis payé j'ai mon salaire
mon travail c'est pas de me déplacer et
d'aller d'amplifier mais je le fais
parce que je suis a maintenant un stand
légiste et j'ai un code de musique et
tout ça mais la sauce et c'est du
bénévolat parce que moi je peux
travailler sur mon salaire
l'universitaire dans un projet de
recherche si on veut l'appeler comme ça
à identifier les morts mais les les
choses que je dois à racheter pour le la
d'un ça et c'est là l'argent qu'il faut
dépenser ses superstars qui le donne et
donc on il faut aller avec chapeau
assure c'est du bénévolat pour
identifier pour acheter les laits et
chose de laboratoire et quand il ya
celle identifiée les gens quand on a
dans douze drop shock et l'europe à un
des bureaux qui font des
l'identification la police les gendarmes
il faudrait utiliser ça c'est cette
raison ou et dont ils et comment ces
commandants tous les autres catastrophes
il est important que nous parlions je le
disais 2
de ces personnes qui prennent tous les
risques et je me tourne vers vous
ibrahim tounkara parce que il ya cette
image qui revient souvent dans le film
cette épave très fragile on le voit bien
et on imagine qu'il est un peu fou de
s'embarquer à plusieurs centaines de
personnes sur ce type de bateau
alors cette question je vous la pose
vous qui avez vécu cette expérience au
départ du du naufrage qu'est ce qu'on a
en tête pour s'embarquer dans ce type de
bateau quel rêve portons quel espoir
portons au moment où on s'embarquait tel
rêve on a ou embarqués dans ces bateaux
d'abord il faut dit que quand on est en
libye on cherche à fuir la mort on
cherche l'amour et si vous voulez d'une
monnaie tragique et le contenu de ce une
tragédie sans fin est donc monté dans
ces bateaux a pâti des la libye en ce
mois est un espoir parce que ceux qui
sévit en libye est tellement humain que
y'a pas de mots pour le décrire
donc quand tu te retrouves dans un
bateau en ce moment c'est c'est une
clope autant d'échappées donc d'échapper
à ces libyens et on cherche d'abord à
fuir l'enfer l'enfer libyen dans lequel
on se trouve
il ya donc on prend bien en balance une
forme d'espérance et en même temps cette
désespérance dans laquelle vous vous
trouvez
exactement vous étiez-vous étudiant en
droit en côte d'ivoire je me tourne vers
vous didier leschi parce que c'est très
intéressant de décès de comprendre les
motivations et surtout le profil de ces
de ces personnes est-ce qu'on a un peu
une idée de qui sont ces souvent ces
jeunes qui cherchent à rejoindre par
milliers partisane de milliers les rives
de l'europe en prenant tous les risques
on sait pas ce qu on le sait à travers
enfin chaque pays a une demande d'asile
particulière mais en ce qui concerne la
france on sait que
la demande d'asile est aujourd'hui très
marquée par des personnes qui viennent
de l'afrique francophone ou du maghreb
actuellement par exemple les passages
importants à travers la méditerranée et
les premières nationalités ce sont les
algériens les tunisiens les marocains
les guinéens les ivoiriens et et c'est
le reflet des désordres de ces pays
parce que avant d'arriver en libye la
question c'est de savoir pourquoi on
quitte la côte d'ivoire la côte d'ivoire
c'est une économie qui est pas une
économie pauvre ça c'est 5 à 6 % de
croissance par an c'est à dire beaucoup
plus qu'en france
mais le problème de ces pays mais on
peut rajouter l'est tous les pays que je
viens de citer ont le même problème
c'est-à-dire cd et des économies où il
ya des perdants du système
c'est des économies et des sociétés où
la démocratie n'est pas toujours
parfaite c'est le mois pour complice et
on a affaire à des personnes plutôt bien
éduqué souvent pas toujours tous mes
mots mais bien des ducs et c'est le cas
voilà mai mais par exemple quand vous
prenez les pays du maghreb aujourd'hui
et bien les bleus heureusement les
jeunes algériens qui risquent leur vie
en passant à travers la méditerranée
eh bien ce sont les perdants du système
algérien il ya en plus la désillusion du
mouvement politique algérien lui ira qui
se termine mal etc et donc on a ça et
puis on a des flux qui peuvent venir des
pays de l'est par exemple pendant
plusieurs années en france les premières
nationalités en demande d'asile c'était
les albanais les géorgiens aujourd'hui
par exemple on a beaucoup d'ukrainiens
qui arrivent mais chaque pays a ses
spécificités y avait qu avec le recul
aujourd'hui qu'est ce que vous diriez à
des jeunes ivoiriens qui se trouve un
peu comme vous dans l'espoir de
rejoindre l'europe
mais est ce que vous vous auriez des
conseils de leurs données et d'aider un
message à leur faire passer un message à
le faire passer je ne sais pas parce que
d'abord sachez que on parlera de son p
sans une raison qui n'est pas fondée ils
sont parfois de sempé par plaisir quelle
que soit la raison il ya une raison qui
pousse quelqu'un a pâti de son père papa
de son pays comme ça
donc ceux qui sont pas en côte d'ivoire
moi ce que je peut le souhaiter que ce
qui m'est arrivé moi personnellement ne
leur arrive pas afin que l'histoire
partie des déchets heures et c'est
encore devra construire l'avenir
et malgré cela c'est bien acquis
décideurs qui sont forcés à partie en
tout cas qui s'élançait parce que
souvent la désinformation fait que vous
avez été désinformés vous par exemple
moi dans mon cas j'ai pas été des
enfants mais ben j'sais pas été informé
non plus n'était pas au courant des
risques vous y est allé un jour j'étais
dans un pays gitane algérie j'ai
travaillé je me plaisait mais j'ai été
obligé des parties de l'italie et
pendant de l'algérie à cause d un
problème entre les migrants subsahariens
et les algériens ce qui m'a obligé à
fuir l'algérie palais en libye et quand
je veux se retrouver en libye c'est là
je me suis rendu compte
l'enfer dans lequel je me suis je me
retrouvais cela vous n'aviez pas et vous
n'étiez pas informé simplement et
l'apathie de son moi je n'avais pas de
retour possible
dre que nous regardions un autre extrait
du film peut-être peut-être l'un des
plus bouleversants c'est la lecture de
ces fragments d'une lettre d'amour qui
était retrouvé dans les effets
personnels d'une victime du naufrage
je ne te dis pas des choses très
mon amour vellaye je ne dis pas des
choses très amour j'espère te retrouver
il n'est pas vieux il est jeune quand
est-ce que sa façon d'écrire
la love you des trucs de jeunes
voilà ça rejoint ce que vous dites un
christina cattaneo dans le film observer
ces morts c'est comme regarder une photo
intacte et pur de leurs espoirs
je me tourne maintenant vers nos deux
invités qui ont en charge l'un comme
haut fonctionnaire l'autre comme comme
politique de concevoir des d'appliquer
des politiques migratoires comme quand
on regarde ces images quand on a cette
charge là est-ce que ce qu'on voit là
change non seulement la manière de voir
mais peut-être la manière de faire la
manière d'appliquer des politiques
didier leschi je sais pas si ça change
[Musique]
on est quand même dans le prolongement
de drames humains terrible avec des
situations d'une certaine manière qui ne
sont pas nouvelles sur de la longue
durée enfin moi quand j'étais jeune les
réfugiés qui venait venait du chili
d'argentine du portugal d'espagne
on avait spécificité méditerranéenne
tout de même depuis une dizaine d'années
notamment oui même un peu avancé au
moment de la guerre la décennie noire en
algérie avec tous ces algériens qui sont
venus aussi en france mais ce qui est
nouveau
d'une certaine manière c'est à la fois
le nombre et les modes de transport et
l'organisation systématique de filières
qui sont des filières d'esclaves âge on
peut pas dire autre chose ça c'est
nouveau ça c'est nouveau c'est ça qui
est qui qui qui est la donnée nouvelle
et qu'on n'arrive pas à combattre on
n'arrive pas à combattre parce que de
l'autre côté de la méditerranée le
désordre
je dirais des sociétés est à son maximum
et que d'une certaine manière le ce que
peut refléter le filmant en creux
mais parce que c'est ça la donner c'est
que on a du mal au niveau des politiques
européennes des états européens à faire
pression sur un certain nombre de
dirigeants de pays qui sont les
pourvoyeurs de cette immigration du
désespoir parce que c'est ça le vrai
sujet ce ne sont pas des pays qui sont
tous très pauvre je veux dire voilà on
parlait tout à l'heure de l'algérie
l'algérie s'est on sait bien c'est la
rente gazière etc mais c'est comme la
tunisie dur est peut-être mois au maroc
ce sont des pays qui sont à la fois
d'immigration et d'émigration
mais où par exemple l'immigration
subsaharienne est particulièrement
maltraitées dire parmi les morts il ya
les morts à travers la méditerranée via
les morts dans le désert avec celle là
on ne les voit pas ces personnes que le
gouvernement algérien mais aux portes du
désert en dix ans maintenant aller
marcher tout droit et donc notre
difficulté à nouer le pays européens
c'est comment on arrive à un stade à
instaurer je dirais un minimum de
dialogue avec ses élites politiques en
leur disant ce que vous faites et bien
est un problème à la fois pour nous et
pour vous dire pour vous parce que ce
sont souvent comme vous l'avez dit on
peut voir dans le maghreb
20 des personnes éduquées ou qui
pourraient participer de la construction
de ces pays et de leurs richesses qui
partent et pour nous je peux pas dire
que ça dépend ça n'est pas un coût
social collectif jeudi requis que l'on
prend en charge et et que l'on peut en
charge on doit le faire mais on peut pas
dire que tout ça n'est pas ne nécessite
pas un effort des sociétés d'être livrés
je vous voyais au final chef lorsque
didier leschi parlait de ce qui se passe
dans le désert algérien sa série vaut
quelque chose pour vous bien se servent
à quelque chose parce que moi quand j'ai
pas tu es de du mal et en algérie
j'ai traversé le sahara gc ce que c'est
et je sais comme des morts comme des
des squelettes de crânes humains que
nous avons rencontrés chez me faisant et
ça personne n'en parle parce que ya pas
de l'association pour compter ses morts
donc ce qui se passe en méditerranée il
se passe aussi ses passions dans nos
deux héros et parfois n'est pas la faute
des politiques et monsieur d'idées las
il a dit tout à l'heure des dirigeants
algériens qu'ils embarquent des
personnes des enfants c'est le plus
souvent dans des gros camions et à
l'ailé des wc auprès de du sahara ça
c'est les jambes
sandro bondi je reviens sur ce que
disait tout à l'heure didier leschi on
sent bien que le rôle de l'europe et
notamment pour faire pression sur un
certain nombre de pays ce rôle est
essentiellement on a l'impression que
c'est un échec
nous avons eu de réaction après ce week
end
18 avril 2015 direction moniteur celle
dont on a parlé
les réactions politiques et on a poussé
poussé poussé depuis l europe assumer
plus de responsabilités encore on n'a
pas ce nom n'a pas développé des
politiques véritablement efficace nous
savons tous c'est qu'il faut faire il
n'y a pas d'accord politique pour le
faire mais pardon mais depuis six ans on
n'a toujours pas trouvé la clé avec ces
pays d'origine notamment
nous on n'a pas trouvé la clé avec les
pays d'origine pour deux raisons la
première c'est que et ça je sais que je
vais provoqué débat là dessus on n'a pas
évolué et ne veut pas mieux lier mieux
utiliser la politique de développement
pour obtenir une véritable coopération
est une véritable co gestion des flux
migratoires avec les pays d'origine
vous savez ces questions il faut ça
c'est vrai que c'était de l'argent là
bas mais aussi peut-être
il faut il faut il faut aussi développer
des politiques et des migrations
économiques légales en tant qu'européen
parce que il est clair qu'on a un
problème qui va au délà du droit d'asile
qu'il faudrait connaître ça évidemment
totalement et nous devons aussi
stabiliser les lieux qui sont les lieux
dans lesquels les filières d' esclavage
les trafiquants d'êtres humains
développer un business qui n'a pas de
précédent qui est plus rentable et du
trafic des drogues
merci merci beaucoup sandro bondi merci
à chacun d'entre vous d'avoir participé
à ce débat vous lancer effectivement
vous relancer un débat absolument
passionnant sur la place de l'europe et
le rôle de l'europe et la manière qu'ont
les héros bien de gérer 7,7 ce drame
ces drames en méditerranée évidemment ce
débat va se poursuivre sur public sénat
et ailleurs voudrait qu'elle vous donner
quelques conseils de lecture pour clore
cette cette émission d'abord votre essai
paru dans la collection tracts aux
éditions gallimard didier leschi ce
grand dérangement l'immigration en face
je renvoie aussi à votre livre ibrahim
tounkara le rêve brisé parcours d'un
migrant c'est paru aux éditions de
l'etna en 2010
8 votre livre également christina
cattaneo naufragés s'envisage donner un
nom aux victimes de la méditerranée
c'est est paru chez albin michel et puis
un conseil de lecture la déclaration
d'amour à la langue française d'un
réfugié afghan un afghan à paris c'est
signé mahmoud nassimi essai paru ce
printemps aux éditions du palais merci à
toutes et à tous de nous avoir suivi et
à très bientôt sur public sénat
[Musique]